i just had big you up here
and uh we were talking about his
original deal with nipsey
he had a production deal with nipsey
that nipsey signed in like oh nine and
it was for
he's like 10 years right and me and big
you were talking and i was like damn 10
years that's that's crazy right like
when you think about work that's that's
a lot of time right
but you know he was saying he was like
yeah but what people don't see is the
five years
that led up to even being able to make
money right you know what i'm saying
and the idea that well if i got you here
you know i got you here so i could you
know it's almost like you know
investing in something you know what i'm
saying like you should be able to reap
the benefits of that right
and he brought you up in the situation
that you have with megan
and well me and dj had and megan's a
sweetheart we interviewed her she's so
nice
um but we had a conversation and it's
like and i manage artists you know
and um it's it's like yo
i'm not saying that megan wouldn't have
made it with or without you right
because she's [ __ ] immensely talented
but but you took a chance on her you
invested in her
she signed the paperwork um
what would you say like like what did
you learn from that situation
see in that situation man it's it's so
many like loose things with that you
know what i'm saying like
with me and megan she new to the
business i'm new to the business
we had a mutual guide that's her manager
right now t ferris
you know what i'm saying shout out t
ferris well i don't know if we shot him
well i just i just remember paul wall
used to rap about him yeah you know but
this guy
he really took advantage of me and her
not knowing what's going on right
so you know if i was to learn anything i
would just say that like
because people don't know that contract
i had nothing to do with it i'm saying
this guy t
ferris and her mom did the whole thing
so i'm new i'm just excited about being
in the business
you're the baseball guy you got you got
the you you got the bag i just retired
two years in the game right top of the
music scene
right [ __ ] doing the damn thing yeah i
feel you
so i'm not even i'm letting this guy run
all my business stuff because
you know i don't i'm clearly advanced
and i don't know what's going on
also a link to the music industry yeah
so i don't i don't know what's going on
so they do this deal
and you know they bring it to me cool
they happy with it
fine you know and um um
when things hit the fan you know when
the big people come i didn't unders
i still couldn't even understand the
concept of what was happening you know
at the time because it was moving so far
i didn't know a
manager gonna come in one day and sign
like i didn't understand none of this
stuff
so of course when the majors want to
come in the managers they look for any
little thing and they found
these little problems with this contract
and
you know all of a sudden i'm the bad guy
but at the end of the day i just learned
that you know
um that type of stuff you need to just
know about it
contracts you know understand do people
the right way
you know and just try to because i think
you try to be on top of your business
more
well i think that the perception was
that you had signed her to a shitty deal
yeah and and i'm not sure that that's
the the i mean i think that that might
be
obviously misleading that's what social
media reads social media
with that you know like like i say with
the deal like
okay we gave a 60 40 profit split like
we
like nobody gets no which is great you
know people just didn't understand
contracts and they wanted to just blame
somebody
you know they wanted to get out of the
contract they wanted to just avoid it
she just wanted to go to roc nation and
be under jay-z
and all that cap [ __ ] but you know
the thing was all they they never they
never called me they never
said nothing to me they waited for me to
say one little thing on the internet
oh you made me mad right there you know
so it was like they found that one thing
to just turn
everything against me and i i'm clueless
so just imagine
you and a person y'all partners me megan
we
ain't nothing wrong with us
that he was doing this in your opinion
he was doing that
yeah he's handling his business you know
and the next day
she's saying hey [ __ ] y'all you know
what i'm saying and i'm
just imagine you don't even know what's
happening you know what i'm saying you
just like
wha what's going on i've never met megan
never had a problem with each other
always gave her what she wanted never
told her no a day in my life you know
what i'm saying
and it was just like damn you know so
what happened
well of course when you call the t
ferris guy he's
playing both sides doing the end around
he called me crying one day saying that
oh she don't want to [ __ ] with us no
more and like
he know that's going to get me going
like oh she don't want to [ __ ] with us
well
but [ __ ] let's go handle our business yo
well then you go tell her
he said [ __ ] you too you know what i'm
saying that type of [ __ ] wow
the next thing you know she like to this
day man had never even talked about
nothing that happened this guy if you
notice this guy t
ferris you never hear from him he never
say nothing you never
nothing because he don't want to want to
say nothing he claims that
oh i just don't want the fame and this
and that but use the cause for all this
problem like it never was a problem with
me and megan
but this guy he he hides and he like
you know he he he probably gonna try to
you know
say oh oh i'm defamation for character
the stuff he'd like to say i don't care
because i know what the truth was but
you know if it wasn't for this guy when
her mother passed he jumped in that
thing if it weren't for this guy
me and megan to still be cool right now
and as of right now do you still are you
still benefiting from her career at all
yeah i mean we still locked it okay
so people want to say oh you running a
little jade you know and this and that
was like well
that's the only person i knew who
understood what was going on like who
else was i going to call you know i'm
saying
had not i did that rock nation was going
to take everything from him i wouldn't
have got nothing you know what i'm
saying i would have just been like
well they would they look at you like
you're the little guy you know you don't
got nothing we're going to take your
[ __ ] from you
like you don't got it so having